little nosex just attended his first
ever met gala and slayed the whole damn
thing posing with many of his celebrity
friends inside the event
i feel amazing the 22 year old singer
sported not one not two but three gold
looks by versace on the red carpet
before he even stepped foot into the
party that's the grammy winner rocking
an ornate cape which he dropped to
reveal a suit of armor
and yes he shed that layer too leaving
him to stun in a shiny body suit and
inside the event it was selfie city
little nazak snapped pick after pick
with his celeb pals including billy
eilish timothy chalamet addison ray and
dixie dimiglio frank ocean yara shahidi
pete davidson lil uzi barrett jack
harlow and erica badou and yes
yes they are posing in the bathroom
which sidebar has become kind of a
tradition at fashion's biggest night
after kylie jenner started the trend in
2017 with this epic group shot i love it
but back to lil nas x this is a week
baby the singer's epic met gala
appearance wasn't his only show-stopping
red carpet moment this week let me give
y'all something it's only a week it's
going to be a great week
it's going to be a week on sunday the
georgia native had heads turning in this
lilac versace pantsuit with a matching
train at the mtv video music awards
you are serving up some fashion tonight
yeah stop it
shortly after that little nas x took
home the vma for video of the year for
montero call me by your name the top
honor of the night
[Music]
was backstage with a musician after his
big win and he opened up about his
fashion choice and the upcoming
september 17 release of his new album
montero
sex you are so on point right now you
still don't have a shirt on at least you
got some pants and a jacket on now yeah
you know i got to try to dress up a
little bit you know no shirts though no
shirts no let's get rid of those yeah
that's that's more laundry i mean
less time who wants more laundry it's
like for the bird
not for little knives not for me you
know what it is for me september 17th my
new album ontario yeah baby he's having
a baby you are just feeling
next level right now i'm feeling like
i'm on cloud like 179
000 million
google
what are you gonna do tonight to
celebrate bed i'm gonna have a great
time with my brothers and my friends
and you know just celebrate and live in
this moment about right now right now is
what matters
yes oh my god i'm so thankful i'm so
thankful
you